[Applause]
to that men on Batman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
[Applause]
give it up for the stars of star wars
the 500 first ladies and gentlemen
welcome to fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I am mark Renard we are in Prince
George at the northern fan comp put your
hands together to the folks at home know
you're real you're real all right real
far from [ __ ] everything man holy
[ __ ] I had no idea I was going this far
north this morning when I got up I was
like Prince George is that a Vancouver
supper and it was not like I flew over
[ __ ] mountains to get here I was like
what happens if we go down the leg it
wouldn't be good but it's beautiful like
it's crazy there's they make you travel
to get here this is in northern British
Columbia I've been to British Columbia
many times but the southern part where
all the [ __ ] Hicks live uh down south
but apparently I've never been here this
is gorgeous
I've never been this far north of
anywhere ever really yeah no this is
like I went to I was out last night for
for drinks I had absinthe it's a bad
idea don't ever do that and I can't guy
absence I heard yeah in the frontier you
can totally get absent really like we
[ __ ] with the Green Fairy hard because
there's no one to see it and I was
coming back and like the Sun was still
out and it was like 10 o'clock at night
and I had no idea what the [ __ ] was
going on
does it stay light out yes sunset was
like what 9:45 like I got some of that
Alaska [ __ ] going on
I've been an Alaskan man there was one
night where it was all day like it was
dark for 45 minutes and I was like well
that makes sense finally and then it got
light again and I was like this [ __ ]
state's broken no wonder we keep it so
far away no really
yeah man we are [ __ ] remote but it's
they they got everything I've we drove
through town it's like they got you know
[ __ ] staples so you guys are good
it's all we got in Civilization Man Los
Angeles you drive around like six
staples you guys got one your [ __ ]
almost la the we just came out on stage
for those who didn't see at home we were
listening at home - what'd you call him
a phalanx a phalanx phalanx yeah
I've pronounced it the southern way
phalanx of stormtroopers yeah and Darth
Vader himself and and Boba Fett and you
know I I've been a Star Wars fan my
whole life and I've been a hockey fan my
whole life I never imagined I'd be on a
stage in a hockey rink with Darth Vader
[Laughter]
[ __ ] pretty impressive man that's
awesome um right now northern fan con is
going on you've been - it is I've been
here since Thursday night choking up
living in the warm maple colored bosom
of a Prince George it's been lovely I
really good crowd you ran into Ming Chen
I heard I ran into Ming who in case you
were ever sort of lost in the wilderness
and need somebody to take you to the
best restaurant where they will serve
you absinthe wait too early in the night
Ming is your man he will absolutely make
sure that you get like a little polluted
but also walk you home so he's a really
good date tell him that it's on the reel
reveal though by a man last night I was
fascinated by this what did you learn
about pastures
I learned about Prince George that there
are no strip clubs in Prince George
is that a lie damn y'all a dirty I found
the little hard to believe I'm like
they're so remote there must be nudity
here somewhere
no the woman who the woman who drove me
from the hotel to the convention today
was like yeah there's uh there's that we
don't have those here there's no maybe
she was maybe she's a [ __ ] Christian
who was just trying to I mean keep you
on the right path or something like she
had something of a convent feel to her
so maybe it wasn't a thing but and then
I broke the news to Ming and he felt
kind of like ah he's like what no strip
clubs that's why I came to Prince George
um what house the convent so far the
Kahn's been pretty cool I mean that
everybody that I've met and I've met a
handful of really lovely folks have been
super friggin excited to be here like
that's one of the reasons I love
conventions period one of the reasons I
love kind of small-town commenter's is
that because they don't get that much of
this love when it shows up it's super
[ __ ] awesome yeah and so everybody's
been really really generous with their
spirit and with their time and yeah I've
had a blast the we got a nice crowd
showed up here tonight and I can't
imagine anything else is going on so I
am really surprised the rest of the
town's not here as well I guess my
movies haven't traveled this far north
no it's absolutely lovely to be here
I've been in Canada for the last week
man I I want to Edmonton into the show
with Ralph Garman did Hollywood
babble-on then I went to Winnipeg and
did a show with Jason Mewes to Jane
Salim Bob get old was in Winnipeg when
the Winnipeg Jets won game 7 it's crazy
like it was when we sold tickets to that
show it was before anybody knew that
they were gonna go that deep into that
series and so we sold out pretty [ __ ]
quickly and then all of a sudden they
were like game 7 is the same night as
your stupid [ __ ] show
and yet this is Canada nobody gives up
it like we like Jay and Silent Bob until
the hockey's on then [ __ ] Jay and Silent
Bob so we're all worried that like cats
weren't gonna comes a lot of people on
Twitter will like hey can't you delay
the [ __ ] show like can't you wait
until the game's over and I had nothing
else to do so I was like yeah I'm happy
to do it but the venue was like that
makes no sense
don't listen to Twitter you know I was
like that's how I [ __ ] run my life so
so we went and had the show while the
game was happenin but they gave me a
monitor right at my feet so you know
like of like I essentially did [ __ ]
color commentary all night long I was
giving them the updates to play by plays
and [ __ ] like that it was so it was fun
because you know thank God the team did
well that night otherwise it would have
been a shitty show if I had to check in
again like yeah that's six nine they're
losing or something like that but the
whole night long I kept you know Jason
would be sitting there talking and I
would be looking to my right while I was
talking and then I'd be like hold on one
second it's three one there's a cushion
you know and they're like oh my god is
the best show ever our show improved by
virtue of the fact that we happened on a
historic night you know I'm saying like
they'll remember that show so fondly and
be like oh my god that was greatest show
ever even though it really wasn't
because of what happened that night and
so they you know they were there were
people in the beginning who were a
little like [ __ ] man I can't believe I
chose this over watching Game seven but
I made him feel better cuz I was like
look I gave up some [ __ ] to be here in
Winnipeg today number one
nice weather number do you know I said
but number two like I you know I had
tickets to the solo premiere in Los
Angeles that happened just the other
night
and they [ __ ] built the Millennium
Falcon on Hollywood Boulevard and I live
three blocks from Hollywood Boulevard I
literally could have walked to the
Millennium Falcon took a whiz on it and
walked home you know they probably
wouldn't let me go in the premiere but
still so it was so close it was in my
[ __ ] neighborhood Star Wars was in my
neighborhood
but I was already previously committed
to Winnipeg so I told them that and they
didn't give a [ __ ] because it was game 7
yeah but so anyway I did Winnipeg and
then I was just in Vancouver last night
with Ralph so it's been a Canadian trip
for me man and it's been lovely this
this is a great way to cap it honestly
no [ __ ] like I didn't know where I
was going cuz I've never been here and
and they just everyone kept retimed
throughout Canada for the last week
people like all where you're going I be
like oh I'm going well I'm here in
Edmonton and then I'm going to Winnipeg
and I'm going to Vancouver and I finish
up in Prince George and the smile would
drop from their face like Winnipeg
Winnipeg I have that guru yeah Prince
George be careful the highway of tears
and [ __ ] like that I like that you're
the the ba Baracus of comedy I don't
know where I'm going next and put me on
a [ __ ] plane they'd knock me out I
woke up on a propeller plane to get here
man it was crazy the dude who drove is
in lovely dude who is like full of
[ __ ] information a font of
information about the area and I'm
actually into that when I was a kid I
hated tour guides cuz I'm like I'd
rather watch cartoons but as like a 47
year old man I'm like teach me teacher
like [ __ ] hit me with your knowledge
and and so he was rocking us with who we
were talking about like hotels like so
weird the conversations adults get into
and [ __ ] like that and so you know we
were talking about hotels and I was like
yeah I was surprised that the towns got
as many hotels as it's like thumbin one
I saw another ones getting built there's
like two around me marks and one across
town and [ __ ] I said like there's at
least five six hotels here in town he's
like then you didn't count them all and
you missed a bunch
there's a guy right I guess y unsub but
I said do you know why there he's like
they're building another one right now I
said you know why there's been a surge
in building of hotels is there something
going on like there's a lot of winter
activity here or anything he didn't have
an answer for that [ __ ] that was when
the answers fell apart man like suddenly
there was no more information but anyway
it was we are right in here the dude was
chitchat and telling us all about the
area and I was soaking it in because
it's [ __ ] beautiful man like this is
where you go to like when they say God's
country like it's just prettiest [ __ ]
like a you know I can understand I can
understand why you have chosen to live
off the grid apparently you know as long
as you got a Staples it's all [ __ ]
good and [ __ ] but it's really [ __ ]
breathtaking I've seen a lot of
outdoorsy activity people just walking
around and having a good [ __ ] time
and [ __ ]
taking walks what looked like for health
like by choice you know kind of crazy
and there was a white spot so I was like
oh [ __ ] we're in civilization but once
you get out of here then apparently it
gets like been a near near near man go
further out man I'm gonna stay in the
city yeah but you're here till what I'm
here till Monday morning so I got all
day tomorrow and now you know there is a
strip club you know you could call up
Ming and be like let's rectify I know I
got a I got a pocketful of loonies let's
Pelt them at some strippers sir you're
doing it wrong let them and put them on
the forehead do they wait a second man
that's a good thought they don't have
any paper money and it starts at the
table you've got to be a great stripper
to start getting paper money
I'd imagine it starts at the five is
that the lowest bill so in the states
you could make it rain with like singles
but here you're literally gonna like
take somebody out with a roll of loonies
or something like they're the bass like
for a five dollar bill you also better
make me a grilled cheese this is all
great but hungry I'm not a I'm not a
strip club enthusiast and stuff but do
they make grilled cheese no not the
[ __ ] food there especially grilled
cheese but do they in Canada do they
like [ __ ] tip with loonies or two
knees are you serious
so like somebody at the end of the night
they're gonna there she is
Calgary Kate ladies and gentlemen
congregate is picking up [ __ ] coins
from the state do they have like those
change belts somebody's like I want to
tip you loony but I got a toonie can I
have changed please yes you can
comes out of here
[Laughter]
there's too vivid a word picture a
mirror the child excellent parenting
have you heard anything about solo so
far the the reactions that I saw on the
Internet's which has never been known to
lie is is overwhelmingly positive yeah
it's looking good man yeah even Mark
Hamill is just like I like it I wanna go
see it again I know what happens next
somebody said that Billy Dee Williams
was at the premiere that both Donald
Glover and Billy Dee Williams yeah they
were both and they were both wearing
this amazing red kind of outfit so
watching Billy Dee with a crazy [ __ ]
cravat because for some reason in old
age he's turned into mr. Furley giant
mega Jeff
there's like Donald Glover who looks
like you know what if Prince was also in
Star Wars it's like Oh how does one guy
get to be the other guy
I don't really know but yes give me more
pictures with both of the minute we have
not spoken about this is America we have
not spoken about this is what you think
I beautiful it's beautiful it's an
astonishing piece of visual art he
directed it right um no guy who directed
every episode of Atlanta did it oh here
oh yeah okay but it's thank god man he's
so Donald Glover didn't direct it
there's one of the one of them exactly
where it's just like [ __ ] man if that's
what a good erector can do I gotta turn
my card in you know it's like he made an
epic piece of art set to music I made
[ __ ] tusks so you know I was like I
can learn from this person but
apparently it was another guy yeah but
no it's it's it's funny because this
song I heard the song on SNL cuz the the
very first public airing of what the
song was was on Saturday Night Live and
all right that's kind of cool but until
you see the video until you take it all
in it doesn't quite stand on its own as
as an audio piece of work and absolutely
benefits from watching the picture that
he's painting of the kind of dichotomy
of life in America especially black life
in America and it's it's mind-boggling I
I can't quite imagine layering something
quite that densely and still have it be
both entertaining and frightening but
that freighted with with message and
easter eggs yeah that's what we call
message now Easter eggs it's friendlier
but but yeah it's layered with [ __ ]
message it's it's and it's it's not a
easy song to sing along to no nothin the
chorus like I got that down this is
America do you think there'll be a
Canadian version soon this is Canada
make make that make those loonies
indigenous people you rewriting lyrics
I'm trying to help alright man we got
stories to talk about yes well a you
know I
we both saw a movie that came out a
couple weeks ago and haven't actually
gotten to talk to each other about this
movie yeah did you guys see adventures
infinity war [ __ ] made it all the way
up here yeah we haven't had a chance job
about it we jawed about it separately
yes I love that you reviewed it as well
what did you say I said that I I have
this weird emotional distance to the
movie because it takes you like 40
minutes into watching Avengers infinity
war to realize that it's not actually
about the Avengers so you show up and
you're like oh what's what's cap doing I
don't know they're never gonna tell me
hey all right so I guess go at which
envisioned a kind of in love but we only
get there for like two minutes
but it's Thanos his story yeah the movie
is about fan OHS and he's your
protagonist and so the movie and the
characters are involved in the movie
you're only involved in as much as they
tangent into fan OHS and it took me a
while to kind of get up to speed with
that because I was a little I was not
invested in that much of what happened
because the movies not invested in what
a spider-man what are you doing I'm go
to school one day man oh [ __ ]
the world's going apart I would have
fight stuff like it's not about him it's
not about Doctor Strange it's a little
bit about Tony cuz you're like I was
thinking I might having a baby but so it
just it got me it took a while for me to
get into it right I I can't imagine
putting this movie together like it is
so [ __ ] big big it's epic there's so
many characters so so many plot threads
to have to weave in there's so many
tones to balance like how you how you
get from Doctor Strange and Captain
America to guardians the galaxy and Thor
and make it all feel like it's part of
the same movie and not this weird
collage of different kinds of films it's
remarkable in just a we managed to make
this whole together kind of weird that
the biggest most epic movie of all time
thus far ever made is a comic book movie
yeah and mind you you know they were
able to put it together on green screens
like the pea
made gone with the wind or like oh
that's an epic but you know like
technology grows and you know you grow
with it filmmaking grows with it so it's
like you can't fault them that they've
got it easier than they had it back in
the day like in for Lawrence of Arabia
when they wanted a scene with all the
extras they literally had all those
extras out there in the middle of
nowhere they didn't just duplicate him
like Peter Jackson did with the orcs and
stuff and it's like if you're in the
desert in Lawrence of Arabia and you've
got 4,000 people walking across it and
you got to do take - hey you gotta back
up 4,000 people and then clean the
desert so it doesn't look like there had
been 4,000 people on it yeah that takes
some time that takes a day easy so let's
like let's put them in a separate
category from the Russo brothers because
Ruza brothers have it like tough to keep
all the stories lines going but I saw
the behind the scenes stuff like when
you watch the fighting on Wakanda you're
like oh my god this looks amazing they
must have went on location somewhere and
you know series of [ __ ] green screens
like it's amazing what they could pull
off now including a character that you
just take for granted because the movie
is about him and he's in so much of it
that owes like it's that is such an
insanely well rendered motion capture
character that you just buy it you're
like yeah I guess that's as long as Josh
Brolin and makeup and it's like a lot
more than Josh Brolin in [ __ ] makeups
Josh Brolin with dots all over him and
probably wearing stilts and then they
[ __ ] made him even bigger and so he
interacts with people and has that
big-ass hand and stuff it's really an
impressive [ __ ] achievement when you
watch the thing from from end to end
that his character holds like all the
way through and then you think about
like I remember at the end of Avengers I
couldn't help but think about Justice
League and how similar the movies kind
of were and as much as like you have a
super team dealing with some threat from
another [ __ ] world and stuff like
that and you know Steppenwolf
looked so like rendered like a video
game character and Fanus has depth and
proportion now there were moments in the
movie where like Proxima midnight she
looked a little I wouldn't say rushed
but like she looked a little bit of a
video game character and stuff
but they took their sweet time with
vanos and thankfully so because you're
right whole [ __ ] movie is about him
it's weird I hadn't thought about that
until you said that
Avengers are almost secondary characters
to his story
it's what does the fan OHS want as
opposed to what do the Avengers want and
it's about can we stop finest from
getting what he wants spoilers they
don't I'm sorry is there yeah hey for
those who haven't seen it yet I mean
what the [ __ ] you call yourself nerds we
gave you a couple weeks man so yeah
there would be some spoiler talk right
about now yeah like and and I and I
never did quite so much of what happened
in the second half of that movie
especially Peter quill and and and his
interactions with with lovely boy it's
when he ruins the plan quote-unquote
ruins the plan because of course is a
plan that Doctor Strange saw 11 16
million different variations in there's
only one version that they win and
apparently that's the plan he's enacting
I was that was me coming out of the
[ __ ] movie theater after I saw the
movie man cuz I was just like I was I
went with I was in New York and I took
my wife and she was like do you have to
take me and I was like yeah [ __ ]
we're gonna love this this is gonna be
great she's like we're not gonna love
this you're gonna love it but okay let's
go so when we [ __ ] went like the
whole movie I'm like I grabbed an urn
shakin her and [ __ ] telling her [ __ ]
she don't want to know
marriage totally but at the end of it
she was just like you know she's like I
actually like that she's like I really
enjoyed it she had a completely
different take on it though with Gamora
she was just like he's gone back to the
beginning Isaac what are you talking
about
she's like remember like she eat like
you know Gamora was being pulled away
from her mom and stuff like you know
that's that when he go after he snaps
his fingers he sees the little Gamora
girl she was tying those things together
and I was like you're [ __ ] wrong like
I was like you don't read enough comics
to understand this [ __ ]
let me mansplain it to you so I did
after I came out of the theater man I
was like oh [ __ ] like don't you get
at man like dr. strange said he saw 16
million different variations they lose
and everyone except one and you know and
that's what he had to do he's like
[ __ ] he like he knew in order to
[ __ ] beat Thanos they have to lose
the battle but ultimately they're gonna
win the war and that future version he
saw apparently involved
Captain Marvel based on the last shot of
the movie which had me [ __ ] screaming
I screamed I was at a press screening of
the movie in New York on Monday or
Tuesday of the week that it opened and
when again spoilers cover yours if you
don't want another [ __ ] when it looks
like Tony Stark is getting killed like
fan OHS breaks that thing off of [ __ ]
stabbed him like I literally just lept
forward in my seat was like no like
[ __ ] Luke Skywalker watching Ben
Kenobi get killed and [ __ ] and then you
know turns out that's not what happens
at [ __ ] but then I read The Daily News
review of the movie from the New York
Daily News and they were like there's a
moment this movie is full of surprises
so much so that filmmaker Kevin Smith
screamed yeah man it was it was an
incredible ride and I was deeply
invested but that moment at the end you
know what I forgot about [ __ ] Nick
Fury and [ __ ] like oh then they went to
credits and and I didn't I didn't know
what the [ __ ] post credit sequence
would be and when they showed Nick Fury
and Maria Hill I was like oh [ __ ] I
forgot about them it's they are there's
an Avengers movie they should be in it
and then I was like oh [ __ ] they're
fading away but uh but that and it was a
beautiful fade with him go on [ __ ]
you know he doesn't get to say [ __ ] and
then device when they push in on it I
was like what who who who and then when
they show the Captain Marvel symbol
again my wife's next to me I was like oh
[Laughter]
filmmaker Kevin Smith once said oh [ __ ]
at a moment at the end of this film I
love that moment so much the whole
[ __ ] ride back to the hotel
like with my wife I was like you don't
get it cap Marvel now they're gonna go
back and tell first we're gonna see
ant-man the wasp in like less than three
months then we're gonna see Captain
Marvel that's gonna be set in the 80s
and that's why that device looks so
shitty and old and [ __ ] like that and
we're gonna find out how they met in the
house
Sam Jackson knows how to call her and
[ __ ] like that and my wife was just like
I can't believe I let you stick your
[ __ ] dick in me the first time I saw
the movie was at the tail end of a 31
hour Marvel movie marathon you sat
through them I said there is 12 12 of
the 18 movies there were no no sequels
except for Avengers age of Ultron and
Civil War but so there was no Iron Man 2
or 3 there was no Thor 2 or 3 there was
no guardians 2 there was no Winter
Soldier but it was 31 hours in a movie
theater that culminated with with an
infinity war and so I was just
compromised in almost every way by the
time it started like my spine had fused
solid my knees were powder
I've been consisting entirely on fried
chicken so not healthy I had a lovely
greasy glow about me but by the time we
got to that movie like hey this is a
crowd who'd been waiting for a day and a
half in one place for this movie and so
everybody was as pumped as you can
possibly be for a film and as stinking
as one could be for a movie well the
smells oh the smells a communal
experience it very much smelled like
like a commode all experience is good
but uh but but this was an annoyance as
emotionally invested in ready for movie
as I've ever seen it and when everything
gets quiet and people start fading away
you could hear the air literally suck it
in theaters and it it didn't really get
me until spider-man like spider-man was
the one that got me because again I'd
been sitting through 31 hours of Marvel
movies and watching homecoming just
before watching infinity war which is
all about that movie is all about Tony
Stark saying if I put you in the suit
and you die it's my fault yeah that's on
me and then you get to infinity war and
he puts him in the suit and he dies and
it's all on him and that broke me I was
already mostly broken all that was was
just like the last little bit at the end
of the of the zipper that just opens up
the fly and suddenly I'm just laying on
the ground sleepy
no that was you just kissing away the
last bit of dignity I'll tell you his
performance in that moment and I guess
it's been covered in the press he ad lib
that moment Tom Holland his performance
in that moment is so genuine that like I
bought like even though I'm smarter than
that I'm like oh my god I can't believe
they've killed off spider-man and [ __ ]
but when I didn't buy was when they
killed off Black Panther cuz I was like
oh no that money that movie made too
much money for that to happen he'll be
back for sure you know but Tom Allen's
performance was pretty moving to the
point where I'm like holy [ __ ] man I'm
buying that this kids [ __ ] dying yeah
it's like we all know intellectually as
nerds and fans hey go get right up in it
there you go
that death doesn't mean anything in a
science fiction construct you know we've
seen characters come back from the dead
for 50 years and in the media we love
but it still worked
in that moment you still felt real loss
the magic trick of a movie and you only
feel real lost because you've loved
those characters for 10 years they did
such a great job of setting up that
universe that when they start taking the
toys away from you you're like now
Walter Flanagan a guy from comic book
men we were talking about the movie and
I was like July kid he says I [ __ ]
loved it and stuff and he's he goes to
half and a half on the movies he's not
like me I love them all man don't matter
I'm like [ __ ] tank girl loved it you
know the Catwoman
that wasn't Catwoman loved it you know
Halle Berry Catwoman but for for him
he's more discerning and [ __ ]
so I was like July he goes I loved it
and he said my only guy said what'd you
think of the ending he goes I really
liked it he's gone but for one moment I
thought when they were going in on the
beeper he's gone that it was gonna be
the number four and right there I
started crying because I was like we
missed a better movie but could you
imagine if they were just like for you
know like oh [ __ ] they're [ __ ] in the
universe here comes the Baxter building
[ __ ] but what they gave us was amazing
and I love Marvel [ __ ] teaser at the
end I thought it was really one of their
best teasers I spoke to my mom who is
not a comic book person she's a you know
76 year old black lady who lives in New
York not that you can't be a superhero
person if you were 76 show black lady
who lives in New York but most of them
aren't but she loved Black Panther
because again she's a 76 year old black
lady who lives in New York somehow it
sounds racist but you're getting away
with it I'm getting it that's the one
good thing but so of course she's like
oh Black Panthers in adventures if
anywhere I'm gonna go see that and I'm
like mom you're gonna be really
disappointed if you're showing up for
Black Panther in this movie because they
spend like 20 minutes in Wakanda
and he dies because spoilers I know I
tried to save my mom the heartbreak
because I think for there's there's a
vast segment at least of the American
public that showed up to Black Panther
and that was a very first Marvel movie
they went to oh and and then and and
black panther functions entirely as a
standalone piece of work you need no
context whatsoever
to be able to enjoy that movie and they
sold Avengers infinity war real hard on
Wakanda I saw the real hard on black
panther welcoming people back and you
know get this mad a shield all of that
is the way that worked and so if you
showed up for Black Panther like
what I want to see the sequel it wasn't
a vengeance if any war a really [ __ ]
pissed can you get the wait
it took him fifty minutes to get to a
Conda and then they killed everybody
yeah his [ __ ] is what my mom said on
the phone she rarely curses because
she's a seven he was six year old black
lady who lives in New York but she was
pissed they took away her Black Panthers
I just got a black panther I don't even
know I like this [ __ ] now I do and he's
[ __ ] gone [ __ ] you marvel but yeah
man it was it was a magic trick of a
movie and like every magic trick like
you know sooner or later you're gonna
get to see how it's done and that's the
next movie that's the next movie it's
doing pretty well at the box office I'm
not sure if you've been keeping up made
a couple hundred dollars from what I
understand it's made a couple hundred
dollars it's made five hundred and two
million dollars domestic all the money
then isn't it and 1.3 billion dollars
globally oh I believe hi oh hello
thank you give it up for ladies and
gentlemen I honestly thought we were
gonna get killed for a second I was
house like this out ends man not a heart
attack in [ __ ] California I get
stabbed by nicely dressed lady and
Prince George anyway you were so yeah
and it made 1.3 million global it is
still not quite caught up to Black
Panther yet Black Panthers still beating
it in both of those regards Black
Panther is has 33 million dollars more
internationally and 192 million more
domestically but it's like it's early in
the run it's early it's three weeks into
this movie plenty of time and plenty of
legs
what was the fall-off of the second week
it fell off by more than a hundred but
it was so massive it still yeah I mean
in all of these movies tend to drop off
between you know 50 and 60 percent they
say there's an exclusive club now of
movies that drop by a hundred million
dollars in their second week but still
are insanely profitable yeah and force
awakens just missed it I think
their second week was like 96 million or
something on 96 million drop but
Avengers was infinity war was like a
hundred or over a hundred but still it
didn't matter because it's opening
number was so ungodly so massive so
they're gonna make more of these I think
there was there was talk today I think
there was an interview that Kevin Feige
had done where he mentioned that they're
going to post Captain Marvel bring Ms
marvel into the screen Kamala Khan MS
marvel really really but they're waiting
for Captain Marvel to establish that
beachhead but I think in subsequent
movies are gonna integrate her into the
into the process it also said they're
gonna do the Eternals which you know
look I'll follow Marvel into anything
they you know I remember when they
announced guardians the galaxy I was
like [ __ ] what a dumb idea like a
talking tree and a racoon who wants to
see that like and everybody wanted to
see it so they certainly know what
they're doing the Eternals was never
something that I was very into but like
if they feel like there's something
there I'm all following or all those
people who love the Inhumans
here come the Eternals yeah nobody love
the Inhumans by the way they just
announced cancellation of the Inhumans
they did which we all assumed because
they made like eight of them and nobody
ever heard from them again yeah a year
and a half ago so now we officially
canceled it back to the moon with you
yeah I've said just the other day they
announced that they're not coming back
ABC they announced a bunch of
cancellations didn't they they did the
one that I think cut the deepest the to
thing I think are the deepest to the
nerd heart where the expanse on sci-fi
I'm not sure what you guys we're it
carries up here but the expanses I'm
sorry
yeah expense is gone and Lucifer back to
hell with listen all that sympathy for
the devil
thank you that that was the best pity
applause I mean well he was a pun puns
get pity applause I get pity [ __ ] I'll
take pity applause well but yeah I mean
and Lucifer it had what four seasons
that you're gonna say Lucifer had like
four viewers I don't know anybody that
watched Lucifer did you watch it
I watched it every week did you really I
did I loved it my wife loved it
really yeah it's uh it is it is a
thoroughly digestible incredibly
charismatic and charming little police
procedural with about the devil like
how's that a bad thing yeah and it
wasn't they ever announced like we're
tired into the endless or dream or
anything like they never did because
that's Neil Gaiman does he get a credit
is the best version of Lucifer he does
the it's a front load of credit which
says mazikeen a character and him as a
ginza character really yeah yeah they
bring maize with him but it was it's one
of those shows it was a steady performer
for Fox but wasn't owned by Fox and in
the way that sort of the vertol vertical
integrated economy and sub working is
that Warner Brothers own the show Fox
broadcast the show Fox never made any
real money on the show but it does
really well overseas it does really well
internationally and so Wonder Brothers
was raking it in but Fox was like we
don't get that money we're gonna put on
like Last Man Standing which we own and
we'll make all of that money and so take
care Lucifer see you later last man on
earth
good luck Brooklyn nine-nine shows we
don't own and they canceled those but
the good news for Brooklyn nine-nine is
NBC just picked it up yeah NBC they're
coming right back and it makes sense
Andy Samberg came from Lauren Michaels
SNL world NBC is Lorne Michaels SNL
world that makes absolute sense people
really like that show - one of the most
diverse shows on TV and funny legit
funny show funny and there's there's a
world in which Hulu might step in to
rescue last men on earth and there's
also kind of a no-brainer argument for
DC's new streaming app called the DC
Universe to pick up Lucifer like why
would you not like
the engine is there the cast is there
its beloved by the fans this is a
network that's built for the fan it's
like why not just absorb it and move on
just keep going cuz cost per episode
probably really high on something like
Lucifer where is that set it said Mel a
shot Mel a shot in LA so that's a pricey
little show it sprays a little show but
like not crazy more pricey than like
Titans will be which is their big sort
of live-action splash really yeah I kind
of weird to think about it's like they
have in the last five years we have had
a John Constantine Hellblazer TV show
and a Lucifer TV show to like vertigo
books have been given the mainstream
treatment and it's a shame to see them
get cancelled but like can't believe we
live in a world where that's even
happened at all that anyone gave like
risked a dime on those two concepts
concepts that started on the comic book
page it's a win even though like look
every TV show is born to be [ __ ]
canceled sooner or later so I still call
that a [ __ ] win the fact that they
were able to take Lucifer to the screen
from the page is a cool thing man
and then they got four seasons out of it
like that is no small feat in this in
the modern economy in it in an economy
where Firefly gets 13 episodes the fact
that [ __ ] Lucifer even got on the air
at all on Fox and got a second season is
remarkable
although someday we will learn to not
trust Fox I'm just saying they will
always take what you love what else is
going on in the world of comic book news
well were you uh were you a wild
stallions fan as a kid of course Bill
and Ted man
yeah there's you don't get to you don't
get to Jay and Bob without Bill and Ted
I'll tell you that much after after
making two pictures Bill and Ted
excellent venture and Bill at Ted's
bogus journey in 1991 they're not making
a bill in Ted three yes it's only taking
them now 25 years to put together a
sequel but yeah Bill and Ted face the
music I think this is an awesome idea
it's pretty great I dig it
do you guys know
what it's about because another story of
Bill and Ted face the music I'll read it
to you from the news bill and Ted face
the music will see the duo long past
their days as time-traveling teenagers
and now weighed down by middle age and
the responsibilities of family they've
written thousands of tunes but have not
yet have yet to write a good one much
less the greatest song ever written with
the fabric of time and space tearing
around them a visitor from the future
warns our heroes that only their song
can save life as we know it out of luck
and fresh out of inspiration Bill and
Ted set out on a time-travel adventure
to seek the song that will set their
world right and bring harmony to the
universe as we know it together with the
aid of their daughters a new crop of
historical figures and some sympathetic
music legends they find much much more
than just a song amen
they got my money on that one that's a
good idea
yeah sequel eyes everything I mean
that's the that's the thing ours is a
generation of nostalgia so and it's
never gonna go away because now you can
see what comes out of it like it's
profitable they're realizing that like
there's money to be made in nostalgia oh
did you like Roseanne here's [ __ ]
more you know owed you like this here's
some [ __ ] more so like this is an
example of that where it's just like
they like Bill and Ted let's [ __ ]
sequel eyes bill and Ted are the guys
willing to do it the one guy certainly
is let's check with the other guy [ __ ]
yeah yeah let's [ __ ] do it
I don't know I'm all for it man sequel
eyes everything we ever loved
I see no downside to this one you know
they're making the Captain Marvel movie
now in Hollywood it's currently under in
production in Los Angeles and that
Benning just joined the cast of Captain
Marvel who should plan it's unclear
beyond science lady is in the
description that's classy they're always
they always hire like a classy Hollywood
actor really like holy [ __ ] like we got
Robert Redford for [ __ ] so what
Winter Soldier when close Glenn Close
playing Nova prime and stuff yeah I mean
it seems to be there had been at one
point some kind of feat barrier between
like real quote/unquote actors and
superhero content but it feels as if
either a they
that hey this could be an awesome
retirement bonus if we start a giant
[ __ ] movie that's gonna make fifty
sixty hundred billion dollars I wouldn't
mind some of that cash and also I got
grandkids you know and they don't come
see my other movies they'd love to see
me on screen come watch me Captain
Marvel wouldn't it be great if you see
grandma save the world
yeah that's legit that's for real that's
why I'm what's-his-face Gary Oldman was
in Harry Potter it was like my kids have
never seen any other movie I've been in
before because they can't because
they're all awful and horrible and I
just curse and kill people for all of
them but I wanted to make a movie I
could take my kids to one if I was him I
would have taken my kids to see Sid
Nancy just be like look at that [ __ ]
that's how you got here
cuz I'm [ __ ] good what else you got
Peter Jackson who we haven't really
heard from in a while ever since you
know his ever since the Hobbit movies he
kind of vanished a little bit off the
off the face off the map unless your map
is solely focused on New Zealand and
you've got a LoJack on him so you know
where he goes he is now toying with with
two big versions of a comeback either
he's going to join the the Amazon Lord
of the Rings TV show that they're making
have you heard about this thing yeah
they're doing a billion dollar version
of the Lord of the Rings yeah it cost
them 25 million dollars alright excuse
me two hundred fifty million dollars
just to get the rights from the Tolkien
estate to make a TV show hmm if they
don't make a show they don't get that
money back so Amazon just literally just
here's our money can we please make a
show and none of that money goes towards
the making of the show itself so dollar
one on camera people on costumes on
locations on actors has not been spent
yet so Peter Jackson's deciding whether
or not he wants to join that as a
producer and maybe director thoughts I
mean as much as the Lord knows he's got
a lot of practice at making Lord of the
Rings things but like at the same time
it's like isn't he [ __ ] tired of
hobbits yet like he's at work with tall
people [ __ ]
I mean if were I him that's not where
I'd go although I also understand him
being a little homesick for the thing
that made his bones the thing that that
gave him you know Oscars up the wazoo
the thing that people love there's no
shame and again going back to the things
that people love true but who knows if
he's got new stories to tell in that
world and it's because they're literally
just retelling the stories again not
quite what I'm doing they're not making
up new [ __ ] are they they are because
token wrote a bunch of [ __ ] that exists
in like appendices and indexes and and
summer ilion's and there's a whole
universe of alternate [ __ ] that does not
actually focus on the ring itself and so
I think they're looking to dive into
that material and tell early stories of
Eragon or other stories of middle-earth
early stories about the men of the West
and all that stuff without talking about
Frodo or Bilbo or the ring or Sauron or
anything because again we saw the best
version of that stuff already I was
gonna say like all the [ __ ] that you
just talked about like none of it sounds
remotely interesting to me but honestly
you know my feeling those movies are
about walking so fuck'em but but you
know clearly there's an audience for it
and as game of Thrones is proven like
you know you can go deep into mythology
of something and people will take the
ride you know people I Game of Thrones
exists because of [ __ ] the Lord of
the Rings movies in the first place
totally it seems like the snake eating
the tail in this instance it's an
auroral boast of content what is that
explain the aurora bose is the snake
that eats its own tail that's its name
that's its name aurora bus I believe it
is I might have mispronounced it but I
can totally spell it fair enough
so he's deciding whether he wants to do
that or or a DC movie Oh [ __ ] do that
oh my god he's very good at making
movies and so far they have not been
that that to me is you got your peanut
butter in my chocolate you got my jog
around in your peanut butter together
they taste wonderful yeah because I
think DC is in a very big bad way
starting to recruit big-time filmmakers
get him he's a talented filmmaker I'm an
again like I wasn't a big Rings guy but
I love one of my favorite movies of all
time is heavenly creatures mhm
he's a gifted gifted storyteller so you
give him material that I like look how
seriously he treated that Hobbit [ __ ]
give him some [ __ ] Batman something
that means something never mind
magic rings and volcanoes and blinky
eyes talking about the Joker
[ __ ] why would you what would
you want to see him do let me see if you
can make him with anything keeping in
mind that New Gods which would have been
my pick is now gone yeah I mean not to
take anything away from Ava from Ava but
like yeah that would have been right up
his alley considering [ __ ] Lord of
the Rings what would I like to see him
see do in DC universe Peter Jackson
Peter Jackson DC Universe it's coming to
me no it's coming all right let me see
what would I enjoy the most [ __ ] that
green era I don't think a green hour too
small for a man of that is immense
talents
honestly like give them a like I know
it's people be like too soon but let
that [ __ ] at the Justice League
man like suddenly you'd probably have
the one that you wanted to see I would
imagine
maybe no Justice League dark he's too
big for that like that feels like
Guillermo movie to me caramel del Toro
should be doing Justice League dark
Peter Jackson should be doing like
crisis on Infinite Earths like just
something [ __ ] massive Arkham Asylum
[ __ ] like whoa
Kingdom [ __ ] yes why are you running a
studio man Kingdom [ __ ] come in the
hands of that guy uh
we'd all Kingdom Come that's good that's
good news that makes me happy good I
hope he picks that like I know the rings
are close to his heart and [ __ ] and he
could do it in his sleep at this point
but it's like come on they need help
over there dude do what you did for them
boring ass rings books I still never got
past chapter one I was this shit's thick
heard in the Bible and twice as boring
so he did a great job with those movies
so I imagine he could take [ __ ] DC
stuff and make a magic and whatnot if I
honestly that guy's so talented if I'm
him I'm like here I'm not just gonna
make a DC movie I'm gonna sequel eyes
all the DC movies you [ __ ] hate but
I'm gonna make it my style and you're
gonna love a mother of a retcon Amanda
hell zack snyder's a genius mark my
words could you imagine he pulls that
magic trick off he won an Oscar for
movies about walking trees I think he
could [ __ ] pull it off man good for
him I hope he does that yeah so he
hasn't decided yet but knock on wood
fingers crossed come
here's my favorite story of the week the
original maroon and gold Iron Man suit
worn by Robert Downey jr. in the first
2008 movie mark mark - mark mark well
mark Wan is the big clunky one then the
silver one is the mark - right and then
the mana tree is the paint was stolen in
Hollywood I'm sorry Pacoima which is
like 20 minutes outside of Hollywood but
it was stolen from a place called movie
prop storage the Pacoima prop house told
police that the suit must have gone
missing between February and April 25th
of this year if I was that place I've
been like it was there and then it just
crumbled in the air and disappeared
[Laughter]
but somebody in Hollywood staged a
[ __ ] heist of the Ironman suit and
got away clean and that suit is worth is
the values reported to be around
$350,000
I blame whiplash do you think like what
do you if you if you're stealing that
suit what are you doing with it what are
you doing the Iron Man's because you
can't really sell sexual things clearly
if you're going out of your way to steal
like it that's that's like it's no you
can't sneak that under your armpit
that's pretty noticeable and [ __ ] so if
you're going through that distance
you're definitely putting it on which
it's only gonna fit like a body type of
Robert Downey jr. size and I can't
imagine anybody stealing the Iron Man
suit is that in shape so you're probably
not gonna wear it so at the end of the
day you know like the [ __ ] yeah I
guess here's my pulsar a repulsor wear
how does one and how do you sell it like
clearly you're bought you're stealing it
for yourself there's no like fence whose
expertise is like screen-worn movie
props right I can move this on the black
market I know a guy in Istanbul who
really wants one that doesn't exist so
you're buying it like [ __ ] Thomas
Crown you just could put in your
basement and like masturbate to it slash
on it or in it if you're skinny enough
maybe just put the hand on and like
[Laughter]
and with the Rockets going it's kind of
like you're getting the [ __ ] stark
hand job yeah man I don't understand why
one would do that like that's you can't
that's sooner or later it's gonna come
out somebody will find it and [ __ ]
let's stay hide in plain sight because
they have those like Iron Man statues
you could buy and [ __ ] I guess someone
could put that in their house and be
like no I didn't steal this I bought it
yeah I went to this image catalog yeah
it's a hot topic they got this for like
a hundred bucks like a hundred bucks I
guess I was going out of business that
is a story I guess we'll continue to
hear about for sure sooner or later
somebody's gonna be like I found it it's
gonna be a bald guy in the desert and
he's gonna sell it to [ __ ] Jeff
Bridges and at first you're gonna think
that he's the Mandarin but no no it's
Gandhi I have one more story okay it's a
personal story I wrote I wrote a comic
book about ten years ago called the
highwayman highwayman the highwayman 4dc
I was a miniseries went five issues it
was it was I'll say it very
well-received and poorly selling who
wrote it I wrote it i co-wrote it with
my when my comic book writing partner
got him Adam Freeman DC owned it
outright like that was part of the deal
going into it was DC was going to own
the characters in the comic book we just
get to write it and we got paid whatever
you get paid to write a comic book the
news broke about three weeks ago that DC
and New Line and Warner Brothers are
developing this now as a major feature
film Oh
you're gonna be rich
no I won't be rich at all because DC
owns it all so I get nothing if this
becomes a movie are you [ __ ] me I
will get two tickets to the premiere I
will get a picture with whoever they get
to star in it and and I will get screen
credit based on the comic book created
by so and so and so and so but the the
giant Brinks truck full of money will
not back up to my house who's writing it
don't know that's so weird
like it's it's like you had a baby and
they're like thank you oh this is
adorable you'll never see it again
yeah and they waited like 10 years to
take it away from me he did all the hard
work and like thank you wow man so yeah
good news but not like life-changing
news in any way I mean it's still nice
to have like you know if you've got to
feel good like hey my ideas have
manifested in a comic book have
manifested in a movie so bad but yeah
it's been check is nice I guess yeah a
friend of mine is Andy Diggle who wrote
the loser's for vertigo back in the day
which i think was a very similar deal
and that he wrote it and it didn't
belong to him but they made a movie so
they invited him out to the set I did
some EPK stuff and it's like I created a
loser's isn't this awesome others did
you sell BAM there's Jeffrey Dean Morgan
and we and then he goes to the premiere
and that's the end of that story and so
he was very happy about the processes
like they made a [ __ ] movie about my
comic book but I am NOT like living Mark
Millar style in a castle and Scotland
off of this [ __ ] I am NOT like basking
in the glow of money raining from the
sky like Neil Gaiman does Mark Miller
live in a castle and [ __ ] Scotland
I'm gonna say he does everybody lives in
a castle in Scotland that's all they
have this is castles wall-to-wall cat
and moats and locks I have been working
on in fact I was working on before I
came to the show tonight Hit Girl
miniseries for Mark and it's I'm in on
issue 3 one more shoe to write for and
then I'm done and it's been a [ __ ]
blast like it's fun when you get to play
with somebody else's character IP good
idea like I couldn't come up with that
idea thankfully he did there's a
universe of books behind it because
they've done few
kick-ass miniseries and eckerle
miniseries so I got to play with the
toys and it's been a [ __ ] good time
man real good time it's awesome it was
so much so that I'm like what else can I
write in comics so I think I'm going to
go back and finish my Batman miniseries
Walter Flanagan as well because I'm kind
of in the zone
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you